the 12 soccer players rescued from a
cave in Thailand after 18 days are
speaking publicly for the first time
about their ordeal the team is taking
part in a news conference right now
their coach revealed they had no food
when they set off to explore the cave
nearly a month ago the boys were just
released from the hospital a day early
doctors say that they are in good health
and a Warner is at that news conference
in chiang rai thailand and a good
morning and you can see that news
conference is still going on
here behind me the boys are talking
about their experience in the cave there
was a somber moment just a few minutes
ago as they remembered the Thai Navy
SEAL who lost his life trying to help
rescue them they said that they felt
guilty about this unfortunate incident
they felt very sad and they brought out
a portrait of the seal that they had all
signed and said that they hoped that
this would go to the family but when
they first came in for the news
conference there was a cheer from some
of the people here and they didn't
really look like kids who had undergone
a very harrowing experience they were
sort of badly batting around the soccer
balls here that were set in front of the
stage and then they started speaking in
today's remarks we learned that all the
boys actually can swim now originally it
was reported that they could not swim
but they say it was never true and they
do take part in swimming activities just
last night the team took part in what
they call some confidence-building
exercises one of the boys were called
the moment that they saw the first
rescue divers and he said his heart was
filled with hope now you may remember
the rescue was completed eight days ago
the divers took each boy one at a time
wearing oxygen masks on stretchers
through twisting tunnels in the rock
they have been trapped by the high
floods June 23rd while exploring the
cave after practice and they called as a
news conference but actually the
questioning is being conducted by a man
up there on the stage who's asking them
about their experience and kind of in a
you know in more of a QA kind of session
with this one person
they asked journalists to submit
questions but said they were going to
vet them they said because they were
worried that that boys might be affected
by negative questions and they wanted to
run them past a psychologist now that
also keep in mind gave them the ability
to potentially limit any negative
questions but they've been a very sort
of frank discussion here and a lot of
description of the details of their time
in the cave talking about when they
might have been scared and what they
thought and when they were hungry and
how they stayed together and how their
coach in the cave there with them
supported them Gayle so it's fair to say
Gayle bet everybody in Thailand is
hanging on their every word because this
is being broadcast across the entire
country you want to hear every single
detail of this story and I water in
Thailand thank you very much